[Aplausos]
qual é o espaço da música na sua vida
qual foi a última vez que você assistiu
a um show de música
qual foi a última vez que você escutou o
seu cd favorito
qual foi a última vez que você cantou
para o seu filho na hora de dormir
qual foi a última vez que você se
emocionou com uma música a música é
também uma questão de hábito
assim como comer dormir e beber água
só depende de você acordar de manhã e
ligar o som da sua casa
meu pai tinha uma coleção enorme de cds
eu lembro de um dia das crianças que
levou eu e meu irmão e falou hoje vocês
vão escolher o presente de vocês vocês
vão escolher um artista nacional e
internacional
e eu tenho cds até hoje guardadas
minha vida sempre foi muito musical eu
sempre cantei e eu tenho certeza que
todos vocês cantam também tem uma música
que todos vocês cantam essa música na
frança é mais ou menos assim que souber
pode cantar comigo
nani zaine vez é inglês rápida
tate e em português de portugal é hoje
ele ia te faz festa cantam as nossas
almas
a música une as pessoas o meu coração
sempre foi um coração uso muito musical
mas tem um lugar que eles não vêem o
coração do jeito que eu vejo é um lugar
onde as pessoas passam horas dias
semanas anos
algumas vezes uma vida inteira
esse lugar
eles vêem o coração assim esse lugar é
um hospital onde as pessoas trabalham 24
horas para que o seu coração não pare de
pulsar imagina os ruídos de um hospital
agora o som do coração batendo de o sol
da marca
o som dos alto da médica andando no
corredor
imagine que de repente começa a sondar o
violino todos esquecem aquele momento
aqueles ruídos e dão espaço à música são
transportados para outro lugar e é isso
que a gente faz a gente leva música para
os hospitais de são paulo
o trabalho começou de uma forma
completamente despretensiosa exatamente
no dia das crianças que nós somos
contratados para tocar no pronto-socorro
de um hospital infantil
o trabalho deu tão certo que as pessoas
dos quartos queriam ouvir a música e não
podiam descer porque elas estavam com
acesso a gente começou a subir tocar nas
quartas
depois começamos a tocar na uti e esse
trabalho foi ganhando uma grandiosidade
enorme
nós nos juntamos e fizemos o grupo
saracura
eu e mais três sócios fundamos o projeto
canta passará e hoje o trabalho ele
conta com mais de 30 músicos
profissionais são mais de 100 visitas
por mês
todos os dias tem música no hospital
hoje de manhã teve música no hospital
são dez hospitais públicos seis
hospitais particulares que contratam
gente de forma particular que recebem a
visita de rotina de uma a sete vezes por
semana este hospital que a gente começou
a gente toca a sete vezes por semana a
gente faz parte da humanização
hospitalar do hospital
então tem a prescrição da psicóloga por
favor passem no quartal e depois nenhum
feedback de como foi
são mais de 85 mil pessoas impactadas
por ano todos os nossos músicos são
músicos profissionais
eles vivem da música eles tocam harpa
viola caipira imagine um encantamento
que isso causa dentro de um hospital
muitas vezes é o primeiro contato que a
pessoa tem com a música ao vivo através
de saracura
mas não é fácil ser músico do saracura
algumas vezes a gente tem que tentar de
máscara porque a gente trabalha em uti a
gente trabalha com restrições de
isolamento de contato isolamento
respiratório e todas essas pessoas
merecem esse momento musical
a gente brinca que a música ela é do
zero aos 100 anos ea gente trabalha
muito com bebês bebês na uti neonatal
nos fez uma pesquisa com mães em uti
neonatal que recebem a visita com
frequência e as mães começam a cantar
mais para os seus filhos
elas aprendem novas músicas e elas criam
novas formas de vínculo entre mãe e bebê
além dos bebês a gente tem também os
idosos
nesse caso era de um senhor da
hemodiálise e ele tinha músicas próprias
e ele trazia toda semana é uma música
nova para os músicos tocarem
ele falava que o tratamento médico era
numa mão eo tratamento da música era na
outra
mas além dos pacientes a gente tem
pessoas muito muito especiais e muito
importantes dentro do hospital
quando a gente toca para as enfermeiras
é um momento que a gente pode cuidar de
quem está cuidando
elas trabalham no natal elas trabalham
no novo elas estão trabalhando agora no
feriado muito dedicadas e muito amorosas
e é realmente muito transformador e
dentro de muitas histórias do sakura
tiveram histórias muito marcantes foram
duas histórias do trt foram histórias
muito
marcante uma dessas histórias
foi no hospital pediátrico
a gente ia de rotina na uti era uma
família que há a menina estava sedada
estava sempre sedada mas os pais sempre
queria uma música a gente tocava até que
teve um dia que a gente bateu na porta
essa mãe estava muito abatida e agente
ofereceu a música e ela falou quero sim
que vocês tocam uma música pra minha
filha mas vai ser a última música dela
porque eles vão desligar os aparelhos e
vai ser a última música dela
quando a gente entrou na emoção e ela
falou mas canta uma música alegre
e eu lembro até hoje que a gente cantou
a música da minhoca do leão e do pato
naquele momento a mãe se emocionou muito
e quando terminou a música ela falou eu
tenho certeza que a minha filha gosto
muito da música
muito obrigada espero que vocês
continuem fazendo esse trabalho durante
muito tempo e naquele momento a gente
participou da passagem dessa menina como
se a gente consagrada a sair naquele
momento através da música
a outra história da uti aconteceu com
esses dois músicos
ele estava na uti de um hospital
bateram na porta e perguntaram se a
família gostaria de ouvir a música essa
menina também estava senado era uma
menina que estava em coma ea ea família
falou assim a gente quer uma música e
eles começaram a tocar a música e de
repente essa menina começou a acelerar o
ritmo cardíaco dela e abrir os olhos e
abrir os olhos
ela estava em coma e de repente no meio
música abrir os olhos e ver vermelha ver
um médico veio todo mundo foi um
rebuliço e depois a mãe dela falou essa
música é a música do toque do celular
dela
então olha o poder que a música tem isso
já aconteceu na história do sakura duas
vezes em dois hospitais diferentes
a gente não sabe a científicamente o que
acontece mas aconteceu foi um momento de
despertar muito bonito bom é por isso
que eu acredito que a música toca as
pessoas
ela me toca desde que eu nasci ela pode
tocar na sua casa ela pode tocar no seu
carro
ela pode tocar dentro de um hospital
o nosso brasil é muito muito muito rico
a gente tem samba tem maracatu e frevo
tem muita coisa boa tem muita música boa
e eu tenho certeza que agora vai ter
alguma música que vai cantar o seu
coração que pode trazer paz que pode
trazer alegria e pode trazer conforto
que pode te lembrar uma memória boa que
pode trazer a saudade eu acredito que o
nosso coração é assim
enquanto tiver música vai ter vida e
essa vida aqui ó
ela não para de pulsar a música é o
remédio da alma e quando a alma támbém o
resto tudo foi beijo
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]